i have just chaired the meeting of the
scottish government's resilience
room which meant to discuss the rising
number of new covered cases
across scotland but particularly the
rising number of cases
in recent days in glasgow and the west
of scotland
over the past two days we've seen 314
new cases
in scotland and 135 of these have been
in the greater glasgow and clyde area if
these numbers continue
or and this is the fear if they rise
further then
more people will fall out from covid and
more people may enter hospital
and intensive care we'll also see
growing pressure on our tests and
protect teams who trace contacts for
each person with covid
and who are absolutely vital in our
battle to keep it under control
and we could if we don't uh stem this
tide
see the virus run out of control again
so today's meeting discussed the actions
we can take quickly
and hopefully preventatively to stop
that happening we are particularly
concerned
right now that the level of covet is
high
in three local authority areas within
the greater glasgow and clyde
health board area western bartender's
daily incident rate of covid
is nearly 33 per hundred thousand people
the city of glasgow's is nearly 22
and east renfrewshire's is almost 19.
for comparison the rate across scotland
has been rising in recent days
but in the past few days has been just a
bit
over 10. we can also see and this is in
contrast to the situation in aberdeen a
few weeks ago
the transmission appears mainly to be
happening
inside people's homes and between
households
rather than in pubs and restaurants
having carefully considered the data and
consulted
with local public health officials local
authorities and police scotland all of
whom were involved in the resilience
meeting discussion that has just taken
place
i can therefore confirm this evening
that we have decided to take
the following action from midnight
tonight if you live in local authority
areas
of east renfrewshire at the city of
glasgow
or western bartonshire you should not
host
people from other households in your
home
and you should not visit someone else's
home no matter
where that is the only exception to that
apart from obviously in emergencies or
to provide
care for a vulnerable person it relates
to the extended households that were
established during lockdown
when people who lived alone couples who
do not live together
or parents who live alone with children
under 18 could join with one other
household to provide
mutual support secondly
if any member of your household grouping
is identified as a close contact
of a confirmed positive case of covet
then we are now asking the whole
household to self-isolate for 14 days
again that applies in these three local
authority areas of
western barton show the city of glasgow
and east renfrewshire
and thirdly visiting care homes in these
three local authority areas will also be
restricted to outdoor visits only
um and hospital visiting it will return
to
essential visitors only in addition
those who were previously advised to
shield will receive advice to be
extra vigilant at this time there will
be
more detail of all of this available on
the scottish
government website and social media
feeds later on
it is our expectation that these
measures i have just outlined will be in
place for a two-week
period however we will review them after
one week
i want to stress and assure everybody in
these three local authority areas that
these are decisions that have not been
taken lightly
they form guidance at the moment but we
will also consider if necessary
putting them into regulation and giving
them the force of law
i also cannot rule out that if we don't
see these measures
working and being effective that we may
have to go further however
and i want to stress this point it is
hoped that by
acting quickly in this preventative way
we can avoid having to take
a further action or imposing any further
restrictions
later on i know that the vast majority
of people have been sticking to rules
and guidelines and
i know how difficult lockdown has been
and this situation
continues to be for everyone but covered
continues to be a dangerous and
sometimes deadly virus
it is spreading again particularly in
these three local authority areas
um and we believe that in these areas
it is spreading primarily as a result of
household gatherings
so these circumstances stopping
household gatherings for a period
and strengthening self-isolation for
people who
may have been in contact with the virus
is the most proportionate action we can
take
to reduce transmission taking this step
supports our schools to stay open
and also limits the impact on jobs and
the economy now i know how unwelcome
this news this evening will be for
people who live in these
areas and i know that because i am one
of
you i live in glasgow so these rules
apply to me
as they do to everybody else in these
areas
i won't be able to have my family visit
me at home and nor will i be able to
travel to a different local authority
in my case airshire to visit them
while i know this will be hard it is
essential
the burden of today's restrictions is
obviously been borne by people in these
three particular areas just to remind
everybody that is western bartonshire
the city of glasgow
and east renfrewshire but there's a
wider message here about indoor meetings
that
needs to be heard right across the
country right now
the threat of covet hasn't gone away and
we must all stick
to the rules and to the guidelines that
applies particularly
indoors so please in other parts of the
country stick to the limits for indoor
gatherings
you should not be meeting indoors with
more than eight people from a maximum of
three households and these rules apply
in pubs and restaurants as well
we must act collectively to keep this
virus under control so
i will end with a reminder of the facts
guidance
that encapsulates all of the advice
we're asking everybody to follow
where face coverings and enclosed spaces
avoid crowded places indoors or outdoors
clean your hands and hard surfaces
regularly keep a two meter distance from
people in other households
and self-isolate and book a test if you
have symptoms if all of us abide by this
then we can
give ourselves that chance of keeping
the virus under control
avoid more restrictions in these three
areas that i've spoken about this
evening and hopefully avoid these kinds
of restrictions
being applied anywhere else now finally
there will
be more detail available on the scottish
government's website later for people
living in these three local authority
areas
for those who may be asked over this
period to self-isolate
the councils will be putting in place
arrangements for welfare
support and advice as well but for now
thank you
very much for listening and for those of
you who continue to stick to these rules
thank you for what you're doing to help
us keep
this virus under control